I developed a storyline for Shadow Man
comes back at predetermined moments
through the game there's one point where
he steals a potion just as you're about
to reach it Shadow Man comes running in
drinks it and runs off there's another
moment where you're about to get through
gate shadow man walks up steps on the
pressure plate and closes the gate at
that point you fall back down three
levels and you're gonna have to work
your way back up these encounters were
scripted to make you hate Shadow Man and
see him as your enemy so that by the
time you faced him with crossed swords
at the end of the game you really want
to get this guy because he set you back
so many times it's a way to build an
emotional relationship between the
player and an opponent through the
actual gameplay rather than just telling
it in a cinematic hi I'm Jordan McNair
creator of Prince of Persia this is how
I animated myself into a corner and had
to fight my way out so I was kid in New
York in the mid 70s I was into comics I
loved movies
I grew up on Mad Magazine and if
computers hadn't come along when they
did you know I might have ended up doing
comics animation but when the Apple to
Kim in 1978 I saw this as a machine that
I could first of all used to play games
at home which was never possible before
instead of taking rolls of quarters down
to the local arcade I could stay at home
and play space invaders on the Apple two
as much as I wanted the computer was
also a way that I could make my own
games and I became fascinated with that
this is before the internet so pretty
much everybody was self-taught I
subscribed to creative computing
magazine and then a little later soft
talk magazine which had articles about
how to program and then I would trade
tips with my friends who are also into
computers
you
[Music]
so my first games were copies of
existing arcade games and you always had
three lives and the goal was to get a
high score but now I was a freshman in
college and I wanted to do a game that
would tell a story so that's when I
started programming the game that would
become care Attica it was a very simple
story the princess has been kidnapped by
the evil warlord who's taken her to his
castle and so as the hero you have to
fight a series of karate battles with
the Warriors who are guarding the
fortress
so you're basically running from left to
right you fight one warrior after
another until you reach the end and then
you fight the big bad guy and rescue the
princess so the computer that I was
working on was the apple two and at that
time the Apple was actually the number
one game platform but it had limitations
the Apple to use music capabilities were
at that grade it only had four colors
the screen was 280 by 192 pixels and
everything had to fit into 48k of memory
that was pretty much a hard limit in
those days this was before Photoshop
this was before we had graphics and
animation tools if you wanted to put a
character up on the screen you pretty
much had to do it pixel by pixel so when
I tried to do the animation for the
character I found out pretty quickly
that it just looked stiff and it didn't
have the lifelike quality that I was
imagining in my head so I used a
technique called virtus coping which
actually has a long history it goes back
to the early days of film animation
early Disney animators used film footage
as reference for the animation in the
early films if you look at Snow White
the human characters like Snow White and
the prince were actually animated using
rotoscoping which means that the Disney
animators film the live actors doing the
moves that they needed to animate on
screen and then they would actually
project these frames and copy retraced
them frame by frame to create the
animation that we've seen so I did that
for caretaker I used super 8 film to
film my karate teacher doing the kicks
and punches and the movements that I
needed the character to do on-screen and
then I traced each Super eight film
frame with tracing paper and pencil and
then translated those into pixels to get
it up on the screen that was kind of the
rotoscope 1.0
[Music]
Kerra ticket came out in 1984 and it
became a number-one bestseller so this
was really lucky for me that it happened
when it did because as I graduated from
college instead of going out and getting
a job I actually had the luxury of
thinking what do I want to do next and I
had an idea to do another game one of
the inspirations was the first 10
minutes of the movie Raiders of the Lost
Ark if you remember you know Indiana
Jones and the opening sequence runs
jumps over Pitt almost misses spikes
spring out of the wall you know there's
a gate that's closing and to me like
those actions kind of matched what I was
seeing in platformer games like Lode
Runner and the castles of dr. creep
where you'd step on a pressure plate it
would open a gate I thought what if we
combine that gameplay with a character
who's so human feeling that you feel
like if you missed the jump and you fall
it's really gonna hurt because I mean
really platformer games characters were
kind of weightless you know you would
jump and you would make it or not but
you would float down to the bottom it
didn't feel like you could really get
hurt so my idea was to kind of combine
the basic platform puzzle type gameplay
in a sort of a modular environment with
very smooth visceral running and jumping
animation that would capture the
excitement of the opening minutes of
Raiders of the Lost Ark
the story of Prince of Persia was also
simple like kara ticket involved
rescuing a princess and it was really
inspired by the Thousand and One Nights
and by movies like the 1940 Thief of
Bagdad in which an evil Grand Vizier has
seized power and imprisoned the princess
for Prince of Persia I knew I was going
to need so much more animation running
jumping climbing falling all the
movements that the little character
would have to do on screen and by the
time I did the animation for Prince of
Persia in 85 a new technology had come
along
VHS so using one of the early VHS
cameras a videotape of my brother
running and jumping and doing all those
things in the parking lot across the
street from our high school and then the
problem was how to get these videotaped
frames into the computer after a bit of
trial and error the technique that I
finally settled on for Prince of Persia
was a kind of a analog to digital to
analog to digital I involved several
steps I took the videotape of my brother
and put that on a TV screen in a
darkened room put a 35 millimeter film
camera on a tripod aimed it at the TV
screen and then took a picture did a
frame advance on the VCR took another
picture frame advanced game advanced for
in advance then I took that roll of film
containing about 35 frames down to the
local fotomat the one hour photo had the
film developed and then got back a sheaf
of snapshots which I then scotch tape
together and using a sharpie and
whiteout highlighted the outlines of
each character then put that on a Xerox
machine and came out with one clean
sheet of paper with a series of frames
of a clean white character against a
black background so that contrast was
sharp enough that I could then put that
piece of paper on an animation stand
pointed a video camera at it and ran
that into the Apple 2 which had no video
in this was a special digitizer card
that could get one clean still image it
couldn't capture motion but once I had
that sheet of 9 or 12 individual frames
of the character I could then go in
pixel by pixel and cut them out on
screen using my animation tool and then
run those frames in sequence and so all
of this took weeks of work to get from
that videotape run or jump to the point
where the game was actually playing back
those frames in sequence on
[Music]
when I first saw that character running
and jumping on the screen
it had that rough illusion of life and
of wait but these were the days of 8-bit
graphics each frame of animation Prince
of Persia was a series of bytes that
represented a fixed image on the screen
and then the next frame of animation was
another set of bytes so to do something
like jump in place took 12 frames to do
a running jump might take 15 frames and
the number of frames made the animation
smoother so once you add the jumping the
running the turning the hanging the
swinging all of these things each
individual movement took memory this is
where one difference between computers
then and now became very important
because the Apple two's memory was 48 K
that's less than a normal text email so
that had to contain everything all of
the images all of the backgrounds all of
the frames of animation all of the logic
to make it work all of the sound effects
all of the music everything so with all
the basic animations that the character
needed to navigate through the dungeon
that had filled up all of the computers
available memory
[Music]
so it was June of 1988 and I was two
years into making Prince of Persia and
at this point had done most of the heavy
lifting to get the game working had a
smoothly animated character that was
running through these dungeons climbing
and falling and stepping on pressure
plates to open gates and jumping over
pits almost falling on spikes everybody
who saw the game mood and odd it was
like a great proof of concept but it
wasn't that much fun to play and I kind
of had the sinking feeling as I realized
I've done almost everything I meant to
do but it just doesn't have that
excitement that I was hoping for
also there was a ticking clock which is
that the Apple 2 platform was dying when
I started to make Prince of Persia the
Apple 2 was still the number one games
platform by 1988 there were new machines
that were coming out that had more
colors higher resolution better sound
capability and I was really at the tail
end of the Apple to use life cycle but I
felt that switching to a different
platform would have been like starting
over so the worry was that I could come
out with a game that was great that was
fun
but nobody would ever play it it's
always a problem when you reach a point
in development that makes you question
your initial vision sometimes the answer
is to say you know just believe in the
initial vision execute it it's gonna be
fine but sometimes you discover things
along the way that make you realize that
the initial vision is just a first draft
from the beginning I had the idea that
the main character would not fight that
this was a nonviolent character just
trying to survive in a dungeon in a
violent world that is their spikes that
spring out of the floor there's you know
gates and falling blocks that can crush
you but this is not a violent character
the point is just to get through these
traps and get to the end and rescue the
princess and I have used all of the
resources that the Apple 2 offered to
try to create this I didn't have a room
to put in another character so I was
sharing an office with friends who are
also working on their own projects
Robert cook was working on a game that
became d-generation Tomy Pierce was
creating educational software and every
time Tomi saw Prince of Persia on my
screen as she walked by my desk
she would say combat combat combat you
need combat where this games not going
to be fun and this frustrated me because
I hadn't planned
combat para tikka was a fighting game
the whole game was you meet a guard you
fight the guard and then on to the next
battle and so I would explain to Tony I
can't do that because there's not enough
memory in the computer to also have a
smoothly animated enemy that does
everything that I would need an enemy to
do but when Tony got an idea she
wouldn't let it go and so I would add a
new feature to the game it's a now
now there's torches on the wall no I've
got jawed traps that chomp and add
suspense isn't it better now Tony would
look at the new feature I'd added and
say combat combat combat and with
frustration I realized that there was
something to what she was saying as much
as I wished that it was almost done it
just wasn't that much fun so this was
the problem tears into development I'd
used up all the memory to get as far as
I've gotten but the game was missing
that suspense and excitement a sense of
conflict that had made carracticus so
simple and so much fun
what was I going to do
[Music]
so I can tell you exactly what happened
I'm that day in June 1988 because I
wrote about it in my journal it was
another day in which Tomi had come and
looked at my screen and said combat you
need combat and again I'd rolled out my
usual argument about how first of all
that's not the concept of the game
second of all there's no memory and she
said well in caretaker you used the same
shapes for the hero and the enemy
couldn't you do that I said no because
the hero looks like a likable endearing
kind of character that the enemy
shouldn't look like that and she said
well what if he made enemies a different
color and then the idea came to me what
if I exclusive ordered each bite with
itself shifted one bit over so the Apple
tea didn't have image processing in any
kind of sense that we understand it now
because the graphics were all bitmapped
but one of the assembly language
instructions was called exclusive-or
which basically means if the two bits
are the same you get a zero if the two
bits are different you get a one so as I
was telling Tony for the tenth time why
I couldn't draw a character in a
different color than the one I'd
originally created I realized that if I
used the exclusive or instruction
shifted one bit over this would create a
kind of a shimmery ghostly outline of
the main character and as soon as I said
those words the character's name popped
into being Shadow Man so with Tony and
Robert looking over my shoulder it
actually took me all of five minutes to
write the code that would turn the main
character into a shimmery ghostly
version of itself and as soon as we saw
Shadow Man running jumping and climbing
through the dungeon it became obvious
that this was this was the opponent that
the game needed it was Robert who
suggested that Shadow Man could come
into being when you jump through a
mirror your ghostly self jumps out the
other direction and then once it's loose
in the dungeons becomes your enemy
stealing potions closing gates that you
wanted to open and just kind of wreaking
all kind of havoc so out of necessity
was born this character who ended up
becoming one of the best features of the
game it's a case of where constraints
can sometimes push you to more creative
solutions than you would have found in
the beginning if they had been available
if memory had not been a constraint I
probably would have created all kinds of
monsters and enemies in Prince of Persia
a lot of variety but because there was
no room for any of that I was forced to
dig deeper and came up with Shadow Man
which ended up actually being kind of
deeper and more satisfying at the end of
the game when you confront your shadow
self and you fight him with swords every
time you catch Shadow Man you lose a
strength point and you realize that if
you keep fighting you're eventually
gonna kill yourself so the solution is
not to win the sword fight but to put
away your sword and when you put away
the sword Shadow Man does the same and
then facing each other you run towards
Shadow Man he runs towards you and the
two of you merge and are reunited and
then you get back all the health points
that Shadow Man had stolen from you
throughout the game and with this
restored strength and wholeness you're
then able to fight the Grand Vizier and
win the game that's something that I
wouldn't have come up with if I didn't
have to
once Shadow Man was in the game it was
obvious that that was the right way to
go and so I managed to squeeze out of
the memory enough frames to do sword
fighting so that you can fight the
shadow version of yourself and that was
so compelling that yes all right
whatever it takes got to find a way to
populate this dungeon with guards and at
this late stage I found a way to take 12
K of memory that was hiding in the
auxiliary memory card of the Apple to to
add a guard but this presented a new
problem how do we create the animation
for the enemies so the model for the
animations in Prince of Persia had been
my younger brother who at this point was
3,000 miles away and he wasn't any good
at sword fighting anyway so my first
attempt was to film myself and my
officemate Robert with a sword doing
fencing unfortunately that didn't work
finally in desperation I turned to one
of my favorite films the 1938 Robin Hood
with Errol Flynn and it just happened
that in this film and his climactic duel
with Basil Rathbone there's a sequence
of about six seconds where the two
characters are perfectly in profile
fighting each other so with a VHS tape
of the 1938 Robin Hood I took
photographs of each frame of film and
extracted the moves that the characters
would need to do in order to do sword
fighting and once the guards were in
there the game felt complete now as you
moved through the dungeons you had that
feeling of challenge of suspense of fear
that had been such an important part of
what made carracticus successful
the lesson if there is one you know the
best way that I've been able to
formulate it is that when you have these
two voices two different approaches in
your brain giving you two different
solutions that are diametrically opposed
to really try to tune in to each voice
and think is this the voice you know of
the big picture because sometimes you
can have great ideas that are kind of
taking you off the path of what you
originally set out to do but sometimes
that voice is actually putting you back
on the path the reason that Shadow Man
was the right thing to do I think goes
back to the original inspiration of
Prince of Persia it's basically the
modern version of a swashbuckling movie
and in those old swashbuckling movies
whether it was Errol Flynn or Douglas
Fairbanks or Indiana Jones the hero did
fight so it's completely in line with
that spirit Prince of Persia released at
the end of 1989 on the Apple 2 and as
I'd feared
I've lost the race against time by then
the Apple 2 was a dying platform and for
about a year I had the agonizing
experience of feeling that this game
that I'd worked so hard on which
everybody who played was enjoying that
this game was going to sink without a
trace what saved it was the ports to
other platforms to the PC to the Mac and
also to consoles like Sega and Nintendo
that came out over the next couple of
years and kind of rescued this game that
had been a flop and made it into a head
and that's what actually made it really
clear to me that adding Shadow Man and
combat had been the right thing to do
because on these other platforms the
memory issues that had been so critical
on the Apple 2 no longer existed those
swashbuckling cinematic roots turned out
to be a key part of you know what made
Prince of Persia what it is Prince of
Persia was successful enough on PC that
we did a sequel Prince of Persia to the
shadow and the flame and by the time
this game came out in 1993 we had a new
generation of PCs that could do sound
and music and color graphics way beyond
what was possible in the late 80s and we
took advantage of this adding more
enemies more characters and richer
environments sending the prince on a
journey across a world that got us out
of the dungeon and palace of Prince of
Persia 1 but the basic gameplay the
formula of traps fight and flight puzzle
solving and combat and exploration
I was still pretty close to what it had
been in prince of persia one since the
original prince of persia the technology
has advanced but the basic questions of
game design haven't really changed all
that much when we did the remake in 2003
prince of persia the sands of time we
were working on a much later generation
of console the PlayStation 2 generation
and so for the first time we had 3d
graphics the ability to rewind time
sound music you know all these things
that the Apple 2 couldn't do but we
still had constraints the first draft of
the story for the sands of time had been
much more complicated with kind of a
political intrigue and you know
different factions with the kingdom so
for the final game we ended up stripping
all of that out and going with a much
simpler story in which everybody in the
kingdom has been transformed into sand
monsters and that one decision made it
possible to design a game that was
actually in sync with what you could do
with the controller in your hands
because everybody that you met was a
sand monster so your only options really
were acrobatics combat and running away
and that was a good fit with what you
could do as a player even though we had
the ability to do dialogue and facial
animations and so forth having a large
cast of characters would have taken the
game away from its strengths so in
designing a game story you really want
to find choices that emphasize the
strengths rather than emphasizing the
weaknesses this year is the 30th
anniversary of the original Prince of
Persia and a lot of what I've told you
today I remember thanks to the fact that
I kept the journal so we're actually
releasing these journals as a book for
prince of persia 30th anniversary there
are the journals that I kept at the time
as I was making the game so it's got all
the rollercoaster of all the ups and
downs and this game is going to be great
this game is going to be a disaster and
how do I solve this particular problem
we've also Illustrated the journals with
screenshots of the work-in-progress and
sketches so it's been a lot of fun for
me on this anniversary to have a reason
to go back and look at those old
journals again which
if being in the 80s are you know mostly
on pen and paper